in this episode we're going to use the
algo Lea search platform to implement
full text search into an angular 4
application
algo Lea provides a library called
instant search Jas which we'll use to
implement all kinds of different widgets
into our search with very little code
when you sign up for algo Lea it
provides a default index of Hollywood
actors we'll be using this index on the
first video then in the second video
we'll create our own custom index with
firebase cloud functions the first step
is to sign up for an algo Lea account
and get your API credentials they have a
free tier which is just limited by usage
after you sign up you'll go through a
new user tour and then you'll want to
make note of your search on the API key
and your app ID inside the angular
project you'll run NPM install instant
search jas instant search is an open
source library maintained by algo Lea it
takes care of all the front-end features
like autocomplete pagination filtering
and a lot more in angular I'm going to
add my API keys to the environment file
and specify that get started actors
index if you want to use the instant
search default CSS you can add that to
the head of the index.html file now we
can generate a new component called
search UI component we start by
importing the environment file and the
instant search package we declare a
variable search which will hold the
entire configuration for this search
feature then we pass it the
configuration from the environment file
and to initialize it we call search dot
start at this point nothing will happen
because we don't have any widgets
attached to the search instance so we'll
go ahead and give it a search box widget
and every widget has its own
configuration options the most important
being the container option which points
to an HTML element that will be replaced
by this widget so now that we have a
place for the user to enter their search
we need another div that will hold the
search result we can accomplish this
with the hits widget so we just point
this to another div with the hits ID the
component HTML template is just two
empty divs with the corresponding IDs
let's try it out we
a bunch of results in JSON format and
they're filtered automatically by the
Instant Search autocomplete it's working
as expected it just doesn't look very
good so we'll use the Instant Search
templating system to modify the
appearance of the results in the hits
widget we first set the escape hits
option to true then define two separate
templates for empty and item empty just
displays the string' and item displays
in actual HTML and you can pass it
attributes by using that double curly
bracket syntax if we go back to the app
we can see the results are now formatted
in a much more user-friendly way this
index also has an image path attribute
which has the actors image so we can use
that in the template as well to display
an image with our results you can
customize the results based on any
information you have saved in the Algol
Lea index this gives you the ability to
do complex ranking and filtering within
your search results now we'll go ahead
and add the stats widget that will just
give us a simple printout of the number
of results and how quickly the search
took to execute and let's go ahead and
add one more widget for pagination we
just follow the same pattern as before
and magically our app has pagination
pagination would be useful if you expect
your search to return hundreds of
results at a time the last thing I want
to show you is how to access the actual
array of hits from inside the component
type script instance search has another
widget called the Analytics widget which
doesn't actually do anything to the user
interface but it does have a function
that will return the query as well as
the result if we pull up the console and
developer tools we can see we're getting
the objects back which has the array of
hits as well as a bunch of other
information this can be useful for
debugging as well as sending analytic
events to third parties
that's it for the first episode on algo
search if the video helped you please
like and subscribe and if you want to
learn more consider becoming a pro
member for exclusive content as well as
one on one project consultant thanks for
watching and I'll see an episode to
[Music]